[Music]
sorry I wasn't looking tomorrow's game
are you okay yeah thanks bye here it's
my fault let me help you up I'm Elaine
10 years ago we created the robots who
now do the tasks Americans once did
Thomas Newton was sentenced to 28 years
after he had an illegal robot devil of
himself you hear that robot yeah
[Music]
this new girl is different level I'm
glad you've met a nice young lady I need
you completely focused on getting a
horizontal for me put yourself on deep
program now see you too
it's Charles guy really wants to bang me
so he'll have to take over tomorrow we
do yes Elaine just don't want the night
to end I feel the same
me too Byron E2 pick up your phone I've
never done this before
also has a robot double you were dating
a robot all along you two and I are
running away together don't try to stop
us goodbye Elaine goodbye Charles let's
just talk about this
don't do it
childish
this is terrible they've completely
stolen our lives I'm gonna have to get a
real real job we hung them down and we
kill them um two cappuccinos thank you
you guys don't understand they're not
going to be obedient anymore
they're humanizing they're learning to
feel you won't get married immediately
let's go go away to stop our wedding
enjoy ride is over
hey I get to shoot me sorry I couldn't
resist well fine then I'm shooting you
that's not fair
swimming to shore oh my God oh my God
she's deprogram now she's feral Charlie
wanna Pinky Winky